[Music]
several months ago we discussed one of
the hottest new trends among young
people especially on tick tock it's the
coolest new thing multiple personality
disorder or as they call it now
dissociative identity disorder and just
on tick tock alone there are thousands
of did influencers raking in millions of
views as they talk about their alleged
experiences with this condition and they
even demonstrate what it looks like when
they switch from one personality to
another you know they put that on camera
too because that's how the illness works
they claim
mental illness is now a party trick like
hey look everyone i just switched into a
new personality coincidentally this new
one is just as insufferable as all my
other ones like i don't have any good
ones but uh yeah it's a whole new one
dissociative identity disorder uh in
which a patient supposedly has multiple
distinct personalities multiple
consciences basically inside one head
has seen various waves of popularity it
was frequently diagnosed in the 80s and
90s and then fell out of favor for a
couple of decades only to have seen a
massive resurgence in the last few years
this has also been the trajectory of by
the way baggy genes and i'm not sure if
there's any connection there but i will
say that it's never a good sign when a
mental illness follows the same course
as a fashion trend
although it's to be expected as mental
illnesses are themselves fashionable and
trendy
and that's helped along not only by
social media but by the news media as
well so this weekend there were multiple
headlines floating around about a guy
named leonard stockel who claims to have
10
unique personalities all with their own
names and ages
the new york post reports quote
a man has revealed he suffers from a
rare rare disorder where his identity is
split into 10 different personalities
all with different names ages and
opinions leonard stockel has been
diagnosed with dissociate identity
disorder a rare psychiatric condition
that develops in early childhood as a
result of severe trauma stockel says the
10 personalities are
kovu age 4 hector eight anna a16 cosmo17
ash18 jesse19 leo21 billy23 live24 and
red 26.
the 22 year old calls his collective
personalities his system with the group
of identities sharing one body in each
distinct form of consciousness is the
person or alter leo calls himself the
host of the system meaning that they
that they are the person who has control
over the body most often
now leo explains that he had uh he had
something of a psychotic break from the
stress of taking his exams last year and
that's what led to him getting diagnosed
with did
he also says that he's in a romantic
relationship with a guy named massimo
who i think is a real guy like a
physical real guy
but
if this split personality story is
legitimate it raises some troubling
questions about massimo i mean given
that four of leo's personalities are
under age and one is a toddler
now speaking of those other
personalities he does tell us a little
bit more about them he says
i'm leo and i'm the current host of the
system i love cooking reading and
watching movies and series with my
partner who i live with kovu is our
youngest and we don't know much about
him because he's very quiet we suspect
that he's very traumatized hector is a
very excited kid he loves stuffed
animals and always gets excited about
going to the zoo or visiting an aquarium
anna suffers from anorexia which is hard
for her to front
cosmo is a rowdy slightly slightly
flirty teenager that easily gets in
trouble ash is a little sunshine who
loves to go on vacation and just explore
the world jesse is quiet but very kind
girly and respectful she often takes
care of the body billy is one of our
protectors he always takes care of
safety while we're outside he doesn't
talk a lot and can be verbally
aggressive sometimes but he would never
harm anyone liv is our sexual protector
she knows when someone gets too close to
us and she can handle every situation
red is the oldest and the system's mom
she takes care of a lot of things
showers chores cleaning paperwork and
managing all of our money
oh
okay then
now the first thing we should establish
about this associate identity disorder
is that it's like totally fake okay it's
almost certainly completely vague in
fact there was a survey conducted of
board certified u.s psychiatrists back
in 1999
and out of 300 only 21 percent
thought that uh did was scientifically
valid and the rest thought that there
was not enough evidence to to support it
an article in psychology today argues
that did a bogus diagnosis and cites the
fact that the famous cases which
popularize this condition the cases
which are the only reason why any of us
have heard about it have turned out to
be hoaxes there's a paper by joel perez
published on the national library of
medicine website calling did a medical
fad and then there's an article in the
harvard gazette which points to research
showing that the central basis for this
diagnosis
doesn't hold up to scrutiny
the article starts by pointing out that
multiple personality disorder was coined
in the early 20th century by a
neurologist who was working with a woman
who he thought
might appear to have two personalities
and this is the first that anyone had
coined this term or talked about it and
of course now we're talking about people
like i have 20 personalities in the
beginning it was one person who maybe
there's two
and for most of the rest of that century
the diagnosis was extremely rare and
most people in the world had never heard
about it but then the book civil was
published in 1973
followed by two film adaptations telling
the allegedly true story of a woman with
multiple personalities and uh
coincidentally
since that movie and and the book came
out the diagnosis skyrocketed from there
the only problem
is that sybil was a fraud the woman
invented the whole thing and that's been
proven now
but the real problem as the article
explains is the alleged source of this
alleged mental illness
the psychiatrists who advocate for it
say that people who suffer from the id
they generate these other personalities
as a way to wall off memories of
traumatic childhood experiences so they
create a sort of amnesia
barrier they call it
protecting the patient from trauma
um the issue here is that uh first of
all it's just ridiculous it's it's a
it's a ridiculous cinematic theory and
and and sort of a way of looking at the
human person that you have trauma and so
your mind like is all this subconscious
does all these things and creates all
these personalities to get around the
trump it just doesn't make any sense
when you think about it for two seconds
there's also no evidence
that any sort of amnesia barrier
actually exists in fact
all of the evidence shows that people
with this condition
do retain their memories even as they
switch personalities that's enough right
there to bring down the house of cards
you could see this in our friend leo he
claims not to have memories shared
between personalities and that's why he
can't hold down a job he says
so more than likely he's getting help
from the government what a coincidence
right
except here he is describing and
introducing all of his personalities he
talks about them like their friends
sitting in the room with him if he can
do that then he obviously remembers them
and remembers inhabiting each
personality
the whole did theory collapses based on
that fact alone if you can remember each
personality that means that there is a
central consciousness otherwise known as
you
present the whole time
these are not distinct separate
consciousness then they're just roles
that you are playing
does this mean that nobody in history
has ever had something resembling a
split personality i mean no i can't say
that the article in psychology today
mentions at the very end that you know
there may be very very rare neurological
not psychological conditions that in
extremely rare circumstances
maybe have led to something that might
look something like d.i.d and these
would be people who have actual physical
brain damage
but if there are exceptional cases like
that it has almost nothing to do with
the did
diagnosis as we know it and we could be
quite certain that nobody suffering from
such a thing if such a person exists at
all or ever has existed is making viral
videos about it on tick tock they
couldn't anyway because if they really
have amnesia between identities they
wouldn't know that they had the
condition and thus they wouldn't be able
to say anything about it
so what explains the tick-tock videos
then well
we return to the same issue that i've
talked about many times and i wish more
people would start talking about because
it's a big problem in our society
and that is that mental illness
is fashionable we we have worked so hard
to end the stigma around mental illness
that now the pendulum has swung all the
way to the other side far from
stigmatized mental illness is now
desirable exciting popular in vogue
it's a fad and a hobby basically
like nobody has hobbies anymore where'd
all the hobbies go people have mental
illnesses as a hobby now
when i was a kid we collected baseball
cards um the nerdier kids would collect
uh pokemon cards and for a very brief
glimmer of time we would we collected
something called pogs okay in kids who
talked to your parents about that
they'll tell you about pogs and there
were other little things that came up in
little fads like that things that you
collected we had other hobbies too we
played sports we built legos we explored
the woods we climbed trees we went
fishing you know we did all kinds of
stuff like that
kids don't do that anymore now they just
sit and stare at their screens and they
collect mental illnesses
and just like pokemon they think they
got to catch them all and that'll make
up for the authentic personality and
identity that they lack or so they think
many fake or highly exaggerated mental
illnesses have come along because of
this process
but none more than multiple personality
disorder a condition invented by people
who pretend to have ten personalities to
make up for the fact that they don't
actually even have just one
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content